I've talked with you guys before about
how very few things in life and in
politics are black and white and that
really the difficult thing is to figure
out the gray areas and most things or
gray areas at least to some degree and
unfortunately it's not just that some
people go into this black and white
thinking mode when it doesn't make sense
to do it we actually have a problem
where increasingly our media
infrastructure our political
infrastructure it's based on and it's
even expecting and rewarding black and
white positions which is to say hot
takes hot take culture nuanced even
seeing both sides is not rewarded it
doesn't get clicks and it just is not
encouraged and so we see this vicious
circle where there is less and less
nuanced thinking over time and I could
pink pick a bunch of different examples
but let's just do two from this week to
illustrate what I mean that almost
nothing is completely one thing or the
other
example number one at the end of Donald
Trump State of the Union this week Nancy
Pelosi ripped up Donald Trump's speech
and was seen tossing it on the desk in
front of her and immediately political
Twitter corporate political analyses in
the spin room after the event everybody
had to stake out a position on this and
you had people on one side saying this
is a genius example of resistance and
female empowerment and Nancy saying fu
to Donald Trump and it's the best thing
in the world and then you had people
attacking Nancy Pelosi saying this is
total puppeteering it's worthless
imagery while Nancy Pelosi is part of
the establishment she's a terrible
person she's part of what's wrong with
America and you then had people who
thought it was bad attacking people who
thought it was good on Twitter and
elsewhere and it was just a mess and
everybody just needs to calm down this
isn't a huge thing where you need to
stake out some all-encompassing
definitive position what Nancy Pelosi
did by ripping up the speech was a funny
conclusion to a State of the Union that
was a completely farcical reality show
with Trump behaving like a reality show
host springing medals on people
bringing in surprise guests and in that
context I was feeling similar to Nancy
Pelosi by the end the eye-rolling the
exhaustion from the ridiculousness of
the show and ripping up the speech felt
almost like a fitting conclusion to the
farce of the State of the Union and at
the same time while it was visually
funny and kind of a funny thing at the
end it doesn't really further the
resistance
it doesn't help remove Donald Trump but
doesn't deal with the policy issues that
we are trying to deal with so it's not
terrible and it's not genius it's not to
be attacked horribly it's not the most
powerful example of progressive activism
either it's okay that it's just sort of
funny and doesn't do much for us let's
now focus on the way in which state of
the unions have become reality shows and
half the country loves it that's what's
important not taking a black-and-white
view on Nancy ripping up paper let me
give you one other example and it comes
from the State of the Union Donald Trump
during the speech attacked Venezuelan
president Nicolas Maduro
and then he also had brought in as a
guest in the upper mezzanine Hwang why
though and proclaimed why though the
rightful president of Venezuela and you
had people who were on one side refusing
to even acknowledge Trump's criticisms
of Maduro others insisting that this was
a tremendous principle than defiant move
to fight against Maduro raping and
pillaging of Venezuela so on and so
forth let's calm down Nicolas Maduro is
not a good guy he's been bad for
Venezuela we can agree on that part
while still being 100% opposed to Donald
Trump once again getting the United
States involved in Latin American regime
change through his this time it's over
at propaganda
he brought Juan why though to the State
of the Union when the status of what is
going on in Venezuela is very much in
question the US cannot be involved down
there this is exactly what the United
States should be staying out of it's
disgusting to see Donald Trump do this
and it makes the criticisms of guava as
a us-backed puppet ring true but Maduro
is still terrible it's okay it's not all
or nothing and I could pick other
examples but the point is we get nowhere
when the expectation is that we have to
stake out some black and white hot take
because sometimes things are black and
white but very very rarely and
unfortunately the whole system supports
doing the black-white hot take stuff it
gets shared more it does better on
social media it's more likely to trigger
comments but let's at least try to be
aware of this structural bias and
understand that it's a little more
boring in the gray area but it's actual
reality and that's where we should
mostly be operating I want to give a
quick shout-out to one of our sponsors
VIN Chara watches they're giving my
audience 15% off your entire order when
you go to david pakman.com slash watch
maybe you don't usually wear a watch and
you've been thinking about looking for
one to elevate your look or you've been
thinking about replacing the one you
have
check out vin chair oh it's an american
company all of their watches are built
in small batches from high-end materials
they look amazing and they look like
something you'd spend a lot of money on
but ever even Cheryl watch ranges from a
hundred and fifty to three hundred
dollars I went on their website and
picked out the Kyros in white and silver
really loved the look the combination of
the white face and the beige band really
loved this one they also sent me the
Kairos limited release gold reserve set
totally different style this one would
make a fantastic gift for a couple
people I can think of in my family any
time you see me wearing a watch on the
show I'm wearing Aven Chara watch go
through their collection I know you'll
find something you like and you'll get
15% off when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch